so given your childhood in Toronto would
you rather play hockey or go curling
well I love curly but hockey hockey he's
a hockey guy all right would you rather
play and if madden NFL or NFL 2k yes I
don't know about any I love John Madden
also a bad dad all right would you
rather be on the front page of the new
york times or the back page of the New
York Post front page in new york times
because that means we probably won the
Super Bowl I like that I knew that that
was gonna be the headline right I would
think that'd be the only way i'd be on
her would you rather a micromanager
would you rather delegate no I think
micromanage micro Anna watch in 2011 you
kind of change things up a little bit
right know what I think you know it's a
tough question because I think there's
there's times when you do have to
delegate and there's other times when
it's hey you know what I this is you
know I'm better off giving you this
opportunity to lead and so I think it's
an to give and take really you had a
cameo in an Adam Sandler movie in 2012
that's my boy right would you rather
watch an Adam Sandler sports movie or an
Adam Sandler drama I tell you a sports
movie because I just go back to the
happy gilmore when I thought was awesome
okay would you rather invest in
blue-chip stocks or tech startups blue
chip stock anal stocks i think yet i'm a
little i play it safe that way Johnson &
Johnson right absolutely can you finish
this sentence the 2014 jet season will
be a success if if we play the way we're
capable of playing and I believe we will
okay finally do you hear the fans when
they're yelling j-e-t-s jets jets
absolutely you can hear it yes and you
see the fireman too well I used to see
the fireman head out there if I don't
see him anymore but you know I you do
feel to our fans I've felt it before and
just like the energy of them and I know
how it feeds it feeds my energy my
passion and I know it does our players
as well can you do the Jets chant for me
j-e-t-s jets jets jets all right nice
thank you so much